like a lot of people who use a bicycle
as a mode of transportation I've been in
some wrecks some crashes some of them
involving pretty significant injury at
one point or another and the story that
I'm going to tell you is about probably
the worst that happened to me when I was
a graduate student down in Southern
Illinois at Carbondale
and I'll get to that in a minute I'm
going to sort of like mention just a few
other cases that happened to me because
I used to use a bike to get around just
about everywhere you know once I had a
10 speed as opposed to just a regular
you know old bike that meant mobility
and freedom for me from really
I want to say like 12 13 onward
and so you know I could get to other
towns quite easily going either on the
highway or in some cases going to
Waukesha by taking this this trail that
had been train tracks that were torn up
and then replaced with gravel and so you
know if I needed to get somewhere I
didn't have a car I would just bike
everywhere and I remember you know
having a few crashes here and there was
basically my fault I also got just
nailed by uh somebody who clipped me
while I was in Waukesha riding I think
on White Rock and it was right by this
this bar and bowling alley and the
person hit me and I was so dazed I
didn't like it contact information or
anything and they fortunately weren't
going super fast but you know they they
turned in to this place as I was
alongside them and just knocked me off
my bike going about you know 20 miles on
hour or so and so you know there were
things like that
I'm sure I probably took some you know
knocks to the head here and there and
you know when you fall you get you get
scraped up even if you're wearing jeans
or protective gear like that and I I
never wore a helmet unfortunately I
probably should have been but back then
helmets were viewed as kind of you know
for for nerds and stuff like that anyway
um I I used a bike whenever I didn't
have a car and now that I think about it
I mean in my teen years I did that when
I was a soldier over in Germany I bought
a bike a mountain bike and used that to
get all over the place and then I didn't
really have a bike when I was in college
then I was doing a lot of running you
know but then I also had a car after
after too long
um and then you know in in graduate
school I bought myself a bike which got
stolen and then I replaced it with a
cheap Walmart bike that nobody was going
to steal well and then
um you know eventually that broke down
and then my relatives gave me a more
sturdy bike that had been bought at
Walmart that had like saddle bags and
stuff like that so I would use that to
get all over Carbondale when I wasn't
taking the bus or walking I would bike
from place to place and it was it was
quite convenient and I didn't have to
worry with a crappy heavy bike like that
about anybody going through the work of
like breaking a lock to steal it as they
had done with a more expensive bike and
so I would you know take my bike to
class and I would go into town if I was
going to meet with friends
sometimes I'd get you know
quite Tipsy and uh you know sometimes
I'd lock it up and stay somewhere and
sometimes I'd bike back home uh kind of
kind of you know half in the bag now the
the time that I got hurt so I should
explain you know I lived in this trailer
park that was off of a highway Highway
51 if I remember as were a whole bunch
of other ones and
um you know it was about maybe a mile
and a half north or maybe South North no
north of the campus
and so I would you know ride down
Highway 51 and there was a nice big
shoulder you know Concrete in Parts if
you got further out of town it was
gravel
um but then you would just ride on the
road right and so I used this as a
common way to get in and out of campus
and also Carbondale itself so Carbondale
itself you know the the main drag was
further south from the campus and
they're all sorts of places along there
um you know there was also a philosophy
house on the south side it was called
the philosophy house because a bunch of
guys in the department lived there and
we'd you know hang out have parties
there some of my other friends lived on
that same block so I would you know I'd
be biking back and forth and we're
talking about like you know three four
miles right which on a bike you can
cover very very quickly
so one night
I was biking home and you know I um I'd
go pretty fast especially since I knew
the area and you know I could count on
these um
the roads and the shoulders
as being relatively clear of like you
know car parts or Rubble or anything
like that the main thing you had to
watch out for in Carbondale was sort of
a curiosity a Carbondale it's called
Carbondale because it's a coal producing
region and they don't um use that coal
anymore it's too high in Sulfur
so they have a lot of extra coal around
and instead of using salt or sand like
most places do in the winter for ice and
snow they use coal dust so that stuff
would kind of accumulate and you could
skid out if you weren't careful anyway
I'm biking home it's at night time and
I'm just flying and then suddenly boom
I'm like
you know off of the bike and I'm hitting
the ground and my my leg is twisted up
under me and I'm I'm looking around like
what in the hell happened here right is
this somebody just punched me
and as it turns out they had taken out a
portion of the shoulder like with a
concrete saw they just cut it entirely
out and it you know was maybe a 10 inch
to 12 inch Gap that I had gone right
down into which was gravel and then of
course my bike sort of foundered and I
fell off of it myself I'm lucky I didn't
hit my head because you know there was
like an edge of concrete I could have I
could have killed myself quite frankly
if things had gone a little bit
differently and so you know it wasn't
well lit at all you know the lights were
out in that that area and I um got
myself up and I could see by basically
Moonlight what was going on I was like
what the hell you know it wasn't marked
there weren't any cones somebody you
know in the traffic or road department
had just come along and cut out that
section because they were probably going
to put like a new section in and you
know I could feel my left knee because
my leg had gotten kind of Twisted
I could feel my left knee hurting now
and I could tell that it was starting to
swell
and you know I'm I'm sort of getting my
bearings again the pain is starting to
hit me in waves it's not just my knee
it's my elbows you know I got banged up
quite a bit and I'm like oh man what the
hell so I I pick my bike up and my bike
is fine you know which is great because
I'm still about a mile away from the
trailer park and I lived way way way in
the back of the trailer park as well so
just getting there isn't quite enough
and I could feel my knee starting to
swell and I'm like oh should I walk home
but this is going to get more and more
painful I've got a mile to go it's going
to take me you know normally like
what 15 minutes to do that uh I bet it's
going to take me half an hour now and I
don't know how banged up I actually am
so I got on my bike and stood it up and
it was
you know at first it wasn't that bad and
then after a while it became more and
more agonizing using my left knee
because you know what are you going to
do pedal with just one foot or something
and hold the other one out that would
hurt as well so I'm pedaling along you
know and I get myself down the road and
you know luckily the trailer park you
know kind of goes downhill so I could
kind of Coast but you gotta you know
Meander around a bit and I finally get
myself to my own trailer and I you know
put the bike I leave the bike outside
and stagger up the steps unlock my door
and uh get myself inside turn on the
light because I want to see just what's
going on you know my pants are kind of
torn there
um everything was was pretty messed up I
had scrapes all over the place so you
know I I get my pants off
and look and my knee is already like
swelling up in size and starting to you
know look pretty bad there's a big gash
as well and I'm like oh what am I
gonna do you know uh is this something I
need to go to the hospital for who can I
call to come get me and and take me I'm
not going to get an ambulance that's
that's for sure because I don't have the
money for that
um
and then I thought well maybe I can just
like
take it easy and you know see what it
looks like in the morning and you know
the pain woke me up a couple of times I
took some you know over-the-counter
painkillers uh but of course they didn't
do an awful lot
and I wake up pretty early the next
morning in bed and
um actually at that time I had a
sleeping I had a mattress on the floor
that I was I was sleeping on
um and so it's it's pretty it's pretty
messed up and I look at it now the the
knee is like swollen and throbbing and I
can barely do anything with it I get up
and I realize I can't
I can't do much standing on this knee or
even walking I can kind of hobble a
little bit but it's painful and you know
I'm like well
nothing seems to be actually infected
and
I don't think I broke anything
but this looks like a really really bad
sprain uh it's pretty painful what can I
do so for the next three four days I
didn't go anywhere and I hobbled around
inside of my little trailer you know
fortunately there's just a bedroom a
bathroom and then a big living room and
I spent a lot of time just kind of like
laying on the couch and you know reading
books alternating between reading books
and falling asleep I had enough food on
hand that I didn't have to go anywhere
you know Kansas soup and things that I'd
cooked before and spaghetti and
spaghetti sauce those sorts of things
and I just kind of made the best of it
and you know after a few days
one of my neighbors actually came and
knocked on the door to check on me
because they hadn't seen me around and
they were like I did you leave or
something I mean I see his bike here so
what's what's the deal so I made my way
and it took you know a little while to
get to the door and uh they were they
were relieved to know that I was okay
and that was kind of a nice thing for me
a reminder that I wasn't like totally on
my own at that point
um and I never wound up you know going
to the hospital getting it checked out
um that may be something that had to do
with why later on I tore two ligaments
in that same knee
um years and years and years later who
knows about cumulative damage but it was
uh that was pretty painful and the pains
kind of changed over time I think many
of you have probably experienced things
like this with injuries you know there's
many different sorts of pain there's the
hot throbbing you know pulsing pain
there's the sharp you know you know like
almost a pin is going into your can of
pain there's the dull ache of the
muscles around as they're trying to
compensate right we could go on and on
and on and I'll tell you I I won't say
that I experienced the entire spectrum
of possible bodily pains but I certainly
was exposed to a considerable repertoire
let's say with that leg and then
everything else having to adjust around
it and I was kind of worried that this
had become you know a more permanent
injury it was it was that bad I never
ended up following up with um you know
why that section of row or shoulder for
the road had been cut out
um I was more concerned just with like
getting better and trying to you know
remain on on track for the classes that
I was enrolled in and didn't go to uh
sessions for that
the rest of that week
um
and you know after a while everything
kind of evened out I'd forgotten about
it all together until something jogged
my memory lately I was thinking about
Carbondale and then I remembered that
that crack up and how uh harrowing that
was and you know the last the last thing
that I'll say is you know sometimes
you're faced with these sorts of painful
situations it's pain on this side it's
pain on this side and you've got to
figure out which of the two or three
options you're going to take and none of
them are good getting up on that bike
riding you know the the additional mile
to where I lived going down and settling
myself in uh you know that you know it
was very very painful to do that I was
worried as I was doing it but it sure
beat trying to walk that uh mile to to
the place as well I don't know if I
would have made it had I walked and who
knows what would have happened then
there wasn't anybody on the highway at
that time and it was like you know 11
o'clock 12 o'clock at night so what a
mess that was so anyway there's the
story of my bike injury down in
Carbondale uh and how I dealt with it